[Musique]
la veille de la journée de la vie
j'étais dans une galaxie très très
lointaine
tout est au point arbres nourriture
décoration tous ensemble los héros cette
fête célébrée
j'espère que c'est une cas j'espère que
ces deux cas c'est au sol laventure la
plaie et faire vite elle pensait loi
mais une clé du paci de la galaxie elle
trouva
être lui mais qu'est ce que vous faites
on a vu mon maître maître de mon maître
concentre-toi le père de mon maître
prezioso le maître du père de mon maître
l'empereur palpatine pas le croire ça
tombait très beaucoup de mettre une
chemise c'est la plaie qui nous permet
de voyager à travers l'espace et le
temps va changer notre destinée sur en
es-tu moins bavard babar plus paga
bagarre
des modules de course je vais pas tout
le gps est trop mignon
car oui
cadeau cadeaux cadeau le meilleur
empereur de la galaxie suivante est ce
que tu penses que je pense musique
va joie cela est vrai l'amitié la
famille
[Applaudissements]
mais vous êtes qui vous m skywalker mon
fils je veux dire mon soleil ma lumière
ronda gunta solans tu veux tirer le
premier
après toi